[Music]
all right how many calories do you guys
think a bear eats in a day oh a bear
do you know how much they win during
like eating season
or during life during hibernation during
hyperphagia
friends
is that when they're getting ready for
yep eating like a [ __ ] ready for
hibernation
i want to say 2 000. yeah i was going to
say like 20 000 calories it's 20 000
calories oh [ __ ]
let's go
that is insane 20 to 20. is it 20.
have you seen a bear hunt for salmon
dude that food just by the water right
literally just while the water's going
down it's just jump
yeah you could just catch it mid air
yeah and then sometimes they just
[ __ ] stomp on it and the salmon's
like on the rocks and just [ __ ] takes
a bite and just throws the other piece
away what a wasteful dude huh can you
imagine somebody skins you alive eats
the skin and you're just still alive and
you're like that's my skin dude
that's my body right there so this is a
visualization of 20 000 calories oh my
give a bear that right wait but that
looks bomb but that's all processed
though because if it's 20 000 and just
salmon skin
whatever honey or like whatever they're
just actually way better joe that's not
gonna get the clicks dude
what's the whole salmon
in calories you think like how many
salmons did they have to eat thousands
two thousand you could eat that in one
day but they don't help i mean they
don't give a [ __ ] about the uh the
actual lean meat of the of the fish the
reason why fish is great for them in
their hyper fashion yeah
it's because of the fat the only the
skin the actual fat and some of the some
of the actual like organs and stuff
that's all they really go for so the
protein they don't go down the protein
actually is is too lean to hold on to
the second you go through protein
actually that goes through your body
that's why
i was watching that alone show and [ __ ]
like that when like somebody would catch
like a moose they would have more meat
than anybody in the game and they would
lose more weight but if people were
catching like two fish that would be
enough to last you for like a month if
you had to because of the fat and then
when like a wolverine would come into
somebody's like cash stack they wouldn't
eat all the meat that would only go for
like the organs or the fat uh reserves
all the micro nutrients that's why
a lot back in the day everyone was going
for like the heart and the liver and
then give me the orgasm nutrients and
fat reserve in order to keep your
sustaining the meat is protein but like
it's if it's lean it doesn't do [ __ ] for
you that's why chinese people want only
the kidneys i was gonna say latinos
though yeah they want all the guts and
the
cow brains and things like that it's the
most nutritious stuff to be honest and
now it makes sense they eat the whole
animal though too yeah you know
movement that's happening in the fitness
community where it's just people are
like eating liver and organs and
testicles yeah beef broth
i love the way you said that you're all
testicles
[Laughter]
so the calories it's like 300 calories a
whole salmon yeah oh wow that's it well
it's over like the fillet part of it how
about just the skin they don't stay for
the whole thing oh wait the fillet part
of it is just the meat yeah that's what
i'm saying like that's that's the lean
part actually so if the lean part is 300
calories and the rest of the [ __ ] sam
is probably like 1500 calories at least
278 calories for a sushi roll
salmon sushi 200 calories for a two
night right there
food right now dude i want those those
donuts look bomb as [ __ ] dude donuts
oh fried chicken and dum oh my goodness
can we order some donuts
for you god and it's it's halloween
colors too
i haven't had you get a drumstick chili
dog down there stick it through the hole
of the donut and eat but
wow solid
i can't eat like some jimmy john's down
there that milkshake dude that'll damn i
[ __ ] want some doughnuts so bad right
now
frappuccino a little chipper a lot of
food a dozen donuts a large pizza
[ __ ] big old can you do that in one
day hell yeah yeah that looks like a lot
man even michael phelps would be like
that's a lot of food if you start okay
you got to work out like your ass off
and then you start hungry as hell at
like six in the morning and you pound
that food it'll be easier to eat this
because it's so like mine you go to
sleep and then you wake up and you pound
the rest i think i need two days so
let's say breakfast i could probably eat
the whole dozen doughnuts and i think i
gotta call it quit
wow the doughnuts
yeah then uh maybe lunch i could eat the
whole pizza for sure
and then dinner i could eat the chicken
do i eat more than you guys because i
would totally kill you
in one day yeah
donuts dude one time i went to the donut
shop and the man thought like the order
that i placed was just for like me and
my friend and i was like no that's just
me dude i'm like you just got a dozen
donuts for yourself
can you pronounce a dozen donuts
straight up yeah
if i can yeah absolutely if they're
krispy kremes those are so easy i can
kill that guy come on
that's my absolute [ __ ] it's nice i
really like the glazed blueberry
doughnuts that are very rare i was gonna
say i haven't seen a little blueberry
one that's why i had to add the very
very
blueberry doughnuts in general very very
few places raised glazed blueberry
doughnuts that's famous for those
anaheim next to disneyland yeah yeah
yeah well i thought those are cake
doughnuts
blueberry cake doughnuts uh i don't know
if
it's old-fashioned right it's uh it's
similar
fashion yeah yeah you guys are making me
hungry oh [ __ ] dude why did you bring
this honestly
why did you bring this
jelly filled doughnut guys with the
cereal on it of course yeah i love
donuts but when those are like ever so
slightly stale just barely those
actually suck balls and you need one
with hot coffee hot coffee you gotta
have a donut with coffee bro yeah
dunkin donuts is a [ __ ] you know what i
don't like their i don't like how many
calories have you taken eight in like
one day i think it's an airplane thing
like our airport thing yeah no it is
it's good at the airport no like have
you ever counted like just a food
challenge like if you could pound as
much food as you wanted when i was
bulking i was doing like 5 000 a day
what did that look like right i was
gonna say what bulky what like oh i was
bulking when i was like oh got it okay
i was eating three thousand calories
just for lunch and then i would get
pretty much mcdonald's like money
yeah yeah wait so are you allowed to eat
like [ __ ] food when you're both not
supposed to but i was just i was doing
it for fun you had mcdonald's every day
either that or two four by four so it
would be like every other day i want to
start bulking you gotta bulk dude i
guess that's what i've been doing
the muscle hasn't kicked in yet i put on
a lot of fat of course but it was fun
but you lost it all damn i was trying to
debunk anthony would get the [ __ ]
blueberry glazed doughnut delivered here
right now but they don't have it okay
how would that be i would [ __ ] love
that no you'd be debunked dude it would
be over for you it'll be literally over
for you because it's not rare because it
could be delivered and then i get
delivered to the door that's just like a
mewtwo dude you'd be wrecked dude check
randy's check randy's you guys get
punished
from your body when you eat what
whatever you want yeah yeah of course
yeah that's what makes me sad that's why
you're turning them oh you're lucky
becoming an adult sucks dick ass no
because i get but you guys get older too
bro you feel that i think like the worst
part for me is scare me guys
the word eczema yeah cause cause like i
mean i can't eat unlimited ice cream my
dirt up that i get that makes it flare
yeah because everyone has different
reasons why they get eggs
but for me yet uh dairy flares it up
dairy or like if i eat too many sugary
things found out um or like if i just
wanted a normal american breakfast with
pancakes and all this stuff and if i
wanted to go and just eat junk food
mcdonald's whatever i would say after a
week i start feeling sick like i'm tired
i can't move a week is tough i don't
know if i could do like back to back
exactly well one day though
if i'm healthy for like a month i could
pound down like all day [ __ ] anything
i want and i'm good yeah it just has to
be one day though
does blueberry cake doughnuts count
that's what he was talking about that's
what i'm saying it's a cake doughnut
that's what i kind of thought too when
you first mentioned it
you know what i'm talking about you know
what i'm talking about right come on you
better get a dozen
oh yeah dude
he's got it all right you better get a
dozen i think he's got it
oh randy's you better get a dozen of
them that's not the one i'm talking
about oh
[ __ ] you got wrecked he wrecked you [ __ ]
man correct your ass well you know what
i'm talking about right talking about
they're they're really good because i'm
just going to make a note at that part
[Laughter]
what are the things that you used to
enjoy that you can't eat that much
anymore because you're becoming an old
pizza dude anything any of that [ __ ]
well i can't even do pizza no man not
really because dude remember we did that
pizza challenge we we all ate like a
medium sized pizza to ourselves yeah
i will wake up in the middle of night
with acid reflux and [ __ ] yeah i don't
know what acid reflex will [ __ ] i
don't know what what it is if it's like
i'm more aware of my body now or
whatever but like let's say i go to town
and i just eat like a whole pizza some
crazy high sodium [ __ ]
like i'll it'll feel like i have a fever
whoa
like i feel like i'm like sweating my
ass off and i get [ __ ] hot like if i
eat like that's not your body telling
you you need a [ __ ] like i don't know
but if i eat like instant noodles and i
get like i make three packs of non-shim
i know how that makes you feel shitty
the kendrick bank once i get [ __ ] up
you want me to [ __ ] me up dude but then
when i want to feel better and that then
i think the show
they wrecked themselves
no because you guys like i love soup
soup is like my favorite so like you
guys always want to order pho and i'm
like yeah i want i want it but the
sodium just [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah if i eat
like two bags of those flamin hot
cheetos then i feel like i have a fever
you guys get affected by sodium huh i
could i could [ __ ] lick a salt i
don't yeah now with like flamin hot
cheetos i'll probably just eat like a
handful and i gotta like chill out
before i go crazy for me it's cheese
dude i love like nacho cheese like
cheese on pizza like the fake cheese i
can't do it like
cheese is good i just get tired mexican
food's my favor and like cheese
enchiladas and [ __ ] let's go but then it
[ __ ] me up
my caffeine tolerance is crazy as [ __ ]
now though hey did you know that these
they're saying that caffeine is like
it's actually like a psychoactive like
drug
i mean sure it feels like it feels great
makes sense
cold brew and a red bull next to you
until white guy dude i'm drinking hella
caffeine hey let's go
[Music]
do
[Music]